st. Louis Missouri 1915 the Democratic convention
draws to a close and Wilson arrives to
accept his real nomination for president
at Long Branch Wilson wife the former mrs.
Norman Gault waved to admiring crowds Wilson
wins on slogan he kept us out of war Capitol Hill
April 2nd 1917 the president who prayed for peace
asks that Congress recognized the existence of a
state of war between the United States and Germany
four days later in the white house he signs
the bill to make the world safe for democracy
highlight in history Wilson himself
is blindfolded at the famous fish
bowl to draw number two 5/8 in the wartime draft
November 11th 1918 Germany surrenders
there's armistice in France the peace
that Wilson promised comes again after two
years of war a happy nation hails the end of
hostilities and hate but war is not over for
Wilson Paris France December 1918 he comes to
peace conference against his nations wishes
among those to greet him is General Pershing
then in brilliant Hall of Mirrors first
president to leave American soil sits with
delegates of Allied nations to sign pact to
peace and launch ill-fated League of Nations
onliner George Washington in February 1919 he
returns to a nation glad to have him home but
hostile to his hopes of peace everlasting under
a Council of Nations his last chances the people
his appeal is nationwide in the
northwest he begins his futile
tour from town to town state the
state by train and car in Bismarck
North Dakota thousands cheered his courage
and shake his hand but few heed his word
he spans the nations speaking no
ill and worn by doctors that he
must rest his wife is always
with him but success is not
in car given him on his last birthday
and the ailing ex-president sits with
his wife his high hopes doomed he's ill and tired
in this house February 3rd 1924 he
dies in disappointment mourned by
those who would not listen to his dreams
president and mrs. Calvin Coolidge pay
their last respects as new Secretary
of State Charles E Hughes and wife
but his long mourn passing does not mean
death to his high held hopes of peace
he was wronged in his time but our time
may yet fulfill the dreams of Woodrow of